salut c'est monsieur je sais pas si vous
avez suivi mes autres vidéos mais ya pas
très longtemps je vous ai parlé d'un
smartphone chinois qui est sorti un
modèle de chez lui et phone c'est le
elephant et 2 si je dis pas de bêtises
ajouté 12 je sais plus des 2/3 et
j'étais fondamentalement pas vraiment
convaincu par ce produit j'étais même
plutôt assez déçu et surtout déçu de la
présentation pour moi en terme de
confiance c'est zéro pointé alors oui
les feuilles la présenter ya pas très
longtemps un tout nouveau produit
cellules et fon x et qui est sorti au
mois de juin de cette année donc ya pas
très longtemps j'ai eu la chance de
l'avoir entre les mains ya pas très
longtemps moi encore un peu plus avant
c'était mois de février à barcelone donc
j'ai vraiment attendu qui sortent sur le
marché pour cette fois-ci vous en parler
donc je vais vous parler aujourd'hui du
lait phone x et je vais vous dire au
final si je trouve bien oui ou non par
rapport à l'autre modèle est ce qu'ils
écoulaient ce qui l'intéresse mais je
profite un de l'été jetez moi pour me
faire des petits retour en arrière pour
vous présenter des modèles voilà donc
c'est une petite série l'été on voit
tout de suite puis majeur fond de
plongée on est là
dans la série des constructeurs chinois
wang ewc ghana énormément forcément ils
sont à prendre la température pour faire
du business pour présenter leurs
nouveaux produits
il ya de tout il ya à boire et à manger
il ya du bon et du mauvais là on a un
produit qui est assez marrant c'est le
eu les fon 10 10 la croix ça nous
rappelle très clairement les cônes 10 là
pour le coup le côté pompage est
vraiment assumé regardez-moi ça est-ce
que l'encoche vous rappelle quelque
chose
oui ou non est ce que le dos
vous rappelle quelque chose oui ou non
on est sur un écran 18 9e 5,85 pouces hd
+ 1440 par 720 pixels à l'arrière deux
caméras une de 16 mégapixels une de 5
mégapixels j'ai absolument aucune info
sur l'ouverture de toute façon on est
sur un produit pas cher donc on
douterait forcément ça pas non plus des
caméras a complètement dingue à l'avant
une caméra 13 mégapixels une batterie
3300 milliards eur qui franchement peut
faire la faire il tourne sous un
androïde 8.0 oreo côté processeur on amt
6763 oct d'accord il a 4 gigas de ram 64
giga de stockage
c'est un produit qui dans l'âme en tout
cas est assez lourd on va connaître
il est assez épais on n'est pas un truc
hyper fin
il garde ici la petite prise jack là où
l'iphone 10 m'a plu vous avez une
connectique micro-usb sur le bas les
haut parleurs en bas le bouton pour
l'allumer sur le côté le bouton volume
le capteur d'empreintes digitales qui
est situé ici au centre de l'appareil la
position plutôt pas mal votre carte sim
qui s'intéresse ici sur le côté beau pas
mal faut dire que je crois que de toute
façon ils n'ont pas peur qu'on leur vole
parce que ici voyez on est même pas
tacher même partir en courant avec si je
veux bon c'est une vraie pompe c'est pas
un produit de dingue
il est lourd je trouve super lourd mais
c'est assez marrant parce que y'a des
pompes sont plus ou de moins fait la
part trop vous le dit alors cherchez pas
il n'y a pas de façade il n'y a pas de
caméra trudel c'est pas tout ça il ya
juste un aspect esthétique qui semble en
tout cas avoir des choses à l'iphone dit
cela vous le voyez pas parce qu'à la
protection mais normalement les gels
affichent des gains avec moi vous avez
ici
la marque qui a indiqué à l'ats
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon je sais ce que vous allez me dire
monsieur bretez dur franchement avec ce
téléphone non mais franchement là avec
un peu de recul maintenant je trouve pas
mal franchement je trouve pas mal du
tout parce que c'est vrai qu'il est
normalement de pompes d'iphone deux
produits qui sont vraiment vraiment
vraiment collé à reprendre l'encoche
l'encoche s'est vraiment développée sur
jeu sur les smartphones android c'est
vrai que lorsque je vais rencontrer
début février
il n'y avait pas encore cette grande
engouement président développement tous
les produits est pareil sur le marché
avec cette fameuse encoches aujourd'hui
sont quasiment tous là donc j'ai
vraiment pas faire de mauvais procès à
houston le produit en lui-même est
plutôt pas mal
on est sur un produit d'entrée de gamme
donc forcément pas avec des
caractéristiques de dengue lui les phone
c'est une marque qui tient quand même
pas mal il ya certaines personnes qui
aiment peu une bonne expérience d'autres
assez mauvaise
mais c'est vrai que dans l'ensemble bon
on va pas non plus cracher dans la soupe
c'est par l'alcool mais j'étais dans une
précédente vidéo ce que je reproche
vraiment moi eu des fautes parce que
j'ai approché sur ses derniers instants
au mwc qui va coûter un peu trop
dilettante un côté un petit peu trop
cool
après cela n'enlève rien la marque sont
allés vriendt au sérieux de la marque
néanmoins voilà donc ça je tiens à
préciser ce point là il faut savoir
qu'un coup sûr smartphone vous avez un
grand écran qui occupent 91% de la face
avant
forcément en bas vous avez une petite
bordure il faut savoir quand même
qu'apple a pu éliminer cette petite
bordure en bas en ayant un écran qui va
encore plus bas qu'ils retournent vers
le haut et les connecteurs qui sont de
l'autre côté c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
pas cette bordure exon vraiment un écran
qui va jusqu'en bas par contre ça coûte
beaucoup plus cher donc sur les
smartphones d'entrée de gamme
on ne retrouve pas même sur les
smartphone milieu de gamme ça c'est
vraiment si vous voulez un grand écran
avec une encoche tout va jusqu'en bas là
il faut aller voir du côté de chez apple
ou équivalent mais sur un produit à
moins de 100 euros
pas trop lui en demander non plus le
processeur c'est un médiathèque comme je
disais c'est 1 mt 6763 8 coeurs cadencés
à 2 giga hertz
ce n'est pas une bête de compet mais
pour un produit d'entrée de gamme safra
franchement la faire une mise à jour par
contre par rapport à la vidéo c'est pas
un androïde 8.0 c'est un androïde 8.1
bon ça va pas changer la face du monde
mais faut quand même le préciser
vous avez quand même de la recharge sans
fil dessus et donc c'est vrai que c'est
un smartphone avec un doux envers le
design n'est plutôt pas mal
il a c'est assez élégant la marque
écrite à la verticale derrière ça se
tient c'est sympa j'ai eu des infos par
contre sur l'ouverture des appareils
photos que j'avais pas leur à l'arrière
sur le capteur 16 + 5 vous avez une
ouverture de f 2.2 et à l'avant sur le
13 mégapixels vous à l'ouverture de f
2.4
ce soit à l'avant voilà rien vous êtes
tous les deux beauty mode voilà sous il
vous rendre encore plus beau est encore
plus belle en photo vous pouvez le faire
vous avez bien évidemment un faisceau
noc
vous avez possiblité de m soit deux
cartes sim soit une carte sim et une
carte microsd pour rajouter du stockage
à votre smartphone il disponible soit en
noir soit en blanc a piqué une promo en
ce moment sur banksy vous intéresse je
vous ai mis un lien il est à 137 euros
de 30 au lieu de 160 euros
donc si vous intéresse vous allez jeter
un petit coup d'oeil ce qu'on peut lire
aujourd'hui sur ce modèle de téléphone
on va écouter dit pas ce que vous en
pensez ce que vous avez déjà eu des
modèles du les folles crois que certains
d'entre vous qui ont déjà eu comme dit
mon commentaire ce que vous en pensez qu
est ce que vous êtes plutôt séduit par
l'art où est ce que au final à contraire
elle vous branche pas merci en tout cas
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo puis je vous
ferai d'autres vidéos comme ça j'ai
d'autres produits encore un peu de côté
à vous montrer donc rester connecté une
fois de plus abonnez vous poser des
barrières toujours plus de produits de
teck toujours plus de choses
j'en profite là cet été c'est formidable
il fait un temps magnifique donc merci a
vous abonnez vous laissez moi des jeunes
époux sait plus très bien
[Musique]